salut comment ça va aujourd'hui on va se
parler d'un tout nouveau smartphone qui
vient d'arriver c'est celui là c'est le
readme 8,5 g je vous ai parlé il ya
quelques temps d'uriner huit pros il est
temps aujourd'hui de faire un tour
complet de ce ring 1800 jerry lee m'a
demandé de vous en parler
on a donc sans faire un tour va regarder
ce qu'il en est et vous allez voir
quelque chose qui sont très intéressants
d'autres qui le sont un petit peu moins
mais on est sur un smartphone aux
alentours des 250 euros avec différentes
offres et ça je vous le détaillerai à la
fin vous allez voir c'est intéressant et
ça smartphones qui déjà lorsque vous le
regardez comme ça eh bien il est sympa
il est sympa pourquoi au niveau du
design
pourquoi pourquoi justement et je vais
tout vous dire et bien c'est que déjà il
est léger il est fin ça ça marche bien
et j'aime bien et a vu que je trouve
super sympa c'est regarder ça là là vous
avez un petit un petit décrocher ici au
niveau d'autres boutons qui servent de
capteur d'empreintes digitales
donc ce petit décroché il est sympa
parce qu'il vient un peu le type et et
lui donner un look un peu plus agressif
et on retrouve sensiblement la même
chose sur le dessus et c'est à dire un
côté qui est un peu incurvé
je sais pas si vous allez bien vous en
rendre compte comme ça mais il ya un
côté un petit peu incurvé sur le dessus
ce qui vient le type et le dos après les
très classiques alors à 5 ans réfléchir
monde éclairage sur le dessus donc
staden cette espèce d'alvéolés là c'est
la couleur qui espérons le noir
supersonique il ya également bleu bleu
supersonique mais là c'est lenoir
supersonique qui vient effectivement
renvoyer la lumière et qui vous fait des
petits reflet que nous décrit ici
rémy c'est qu'il ya un look un design
qui est inspiré du film fast and furious
ça le dynamique speed donc pour donner
un effet de justice que si vous le
bouger vite
ce n'est en effet de vitesse est-ce que
là vous avez à l'effet de vitesse à
aller savoir on voit qu'on a trois
caméras et ici en croire qu'en d'avoir
une quatrième faisons un point 4e il est
marqué à vie pour artificial
intelligence
l'intelligence artificielle bon voilà il
ya un côté un peu rigoler parce que ça
porte vraiment de l'asymétrie le petit
flash et donc souvent qu'on ait une
caméra mme principal de 40 8 mégapixels
c'est celle-là lac et planck est juste
là ça on sera dans quelques instants la
partie photo vous avez de la macro vous
avez également un autre capteur portrait
noir et blanc on va regarder ça tout à
l'heure vous inquiétez pas on est quand
même sur un grand écran et si c'est du 6
5 pouces on est dans l'ère de ce qu'on
retrouve actuellement sur les
smartphones où on veut des
sans écran pour avoir du contenu pour
venir voir des films pour venir voir des
séries pour pouvoir afficher plein de
choses on retrouve ici ce qu'on veut un
petit peu usuellement sur notre
smartphone c'est un format qu'on
retrouve beaucoup en 2021 on voit qu'on
a notre petit notre petite caméra qui
est planqué ici un grand classique un
montant qui est un peu grand semble être
nécessairement trop pour un smartphone
autour de 250 euros ça me paraît
complètement normal un bouton sur le
côté ici c'est le bouton de volume en
fait pour venir monter et baisser votre
volume
rien de bien surprenant le tiroir de
karting valeur le terroir carte sim il
intéressant parce qu ici et je vais vous
le dire vous avez un processeur c'est un
processeur médiathèque c'est le diben
city 700 et se dit man city 700 c'est un
processeur 5 g ok ça c'est bien et il
vous permet de faire un truc qui est
vachement intéressant se dit man city
il vous permet d'avoir un double sim
plus carte microsd jusqu'à 1 tera ok
mais double sim 5 g ce qui fait que si
vous êtes frontaliers que vous avez
besoin de deux abonnements 5 g ou deux
cartes 5g une prime parce que pourquoi
pas et bien vous pouvez faire ici vous
avez plusieurs config 4 gigas de ram ou
si giga de ram 64 géant du stockage ou
128 go de stockage
et alors c'est là que remy nous a fait
une techno qui est intéressante c'est ce
qu'ils appelleront la technologie d r e
alors à quoi sert la technologie des
erreurs c'est une façon intelligente
d'optimiser l'arabe et le rhum alors
pour tous ceux qui sont pas coutumiers
tous à la rame
c'est giga de ram 4 gigas de ram c'est
ce qu'il va venir apporter de la
fluidité dans votre smartphone et l'as
rome c'est le stockage est en fait
l'idée ici c'est que lorsque vous avez
une partie du stockage qui n'est pas
utilisé eh bien on va pouvoir venir la
détourner son utilisation transformer la
rom donc le stockage en ram virtuel pour
venir optimiser les performances de
votre machine
ce qui fait que si vous avez un 4 gigas
de ram mais que vous avez beaucoup de
stockage de 10 po et bien là pour en
revenir utilisé une partie stockage
dispo pour le transformer en raz mais
pour booster votre cas de giga de ram
donc ça c'est pas mal et c'est
intéressant et ça vous servira notamment
pour quelques parties de gainey lorsque
vous donne un peu plus de ressources et
d'un petit renfort performante et bien
pouvoir le faire de cette manière là
alors par contre si vous avez à se
cachent plein ça n'ira pas mais voyez un
peu l'idée donc ça c'est malin c'est une
façon devenait vraiment optimisé sa
machine le dit man city 700 ici déjà qui
marche très très bien qui vous apportera
de la fluidité de la performance tout
sous un temps d'un smartphone
bien évidemment on va pas s'attendre à
avoir des performances qui vont
transcender la machine mais une fois de
plus dans son segment de prix ça
fonctionnera avec ça c'est bien à noter
qu'à l'intérieur vous avez une grosse
batterie de 5000 millions perdra c'est
ce qu'on s'attend à retrouver également
dans ce segment de prix donc ça c'est
normal ça marche bien vous avez un
chargeur rapide de 18 watts qui est
inclus dans la boîte de votre smartphone
ayant une techno qui est intéressant qui
s'appelle la smar 5 g power saving avec
l'accent power saving alors à quoi ça va
vous servir tout ça et bien ça va vous
servir vraiment à venir optimisez votre
batterie à optimiser l'autonomie de
votre smartphone parce que vous le savez
probablement peut-être pas d'ailleurs
dit que le mans en commentaire la 5g ça
va venir consommer davantage au niveau
de votre batterie donc l'idée
effectivement c'est avoir une gestion
intelligente ici pour venir gagner en
autonomie
vous avez donc avoir un switch
intelligent 4g et 5g en fonction des
besoins vous aident à voir aussi une
optimisation au niveau du rétro
éclairage du navire diminué en fonction
des besoins
il va venir qu'ils aient des
applications vous n'utilisez pas en
arrière-plan
donc il ya plein de petits paramètres
qui sont intelligents vous allez pouvoir
venir à retrouver ici pouvait venir
économisez de l'énergie que vous cliquez
ici regardez problème trouver désactiver
le gps là ils pensent que ça consomme
effectivement donc on pourra revenir
effectivement désactiver le gps
optimisation désactiver le mode haute
performance il ya pas mal de petites
choses à venir faire vous appuyer là
vous optimisez vous allez gagner en
autonomie
vous avez également un mode économie
d'énergie et vous avez le mode super
économies d'énergie qui permettra
d'aller beaucoup plus loin
vous avez également une gestion de la
batterie de l'ap donc en fonction des
différentes applications j'en serais moi
par exemple un asphalte neuf autorisées
l'activité en a en premier plan autorisé
l'activité en arrière-plan autorisé le
lancement automatique
il ya plein de petites optimisations
quand on connaît bien ces usages qu'on
peut venir faire ici plus de réglages
aussi de la batterie mode de performance
mode haute performance des bars et le
mode performance aucune amélioration de
performance déjà vous avez une grosse
batterie de 5 millions en paire eur et
en plus de ça eh bien on va pouvoir
venir optimiser ses petits points de
détails mais qui malgré tout sont
intéressants parce qu'on connaît nos
usages principaux on sait ce qu'on va
venir faire regarder un film une série
sur netflix allez sur youtube regarder
les vidéos de sucre
jouer un jeu on les connaît donc on vit
bien optimisé ses usages directement au
travers de ce qu'on peut faire ici avec
son expérience logiciel on est sûre il
mieux avec 2.0 basé sur un android
11 il ya plein d'options c'est bien ces
pratiques à savoir qu'ici vous avez un
haut parleur mono ehpad haut-parleurs
stéréo et l'a écouté pour voir qu'on est
sur un petit haut parleur mono une fois
de plus dans ce segment de prix ça fait
le taff ça fonctionne c'est honnête on
n'a pas un truc qui est complètement
dingue où on s'en doutera mais sa frappe
alors si on veut lire et fait vibrer le
script on baisse un peu ça sera un peu
moins agressif mais ça fait le taff et
puis surtout ici si vous le souhaitez et
on le retrouve une fois de plus dans ce
segment de prix vous avez une petite
prise jack
oui pour venir branche est effectivement
un casque si vous le souhaitez ici vous
avez un écran full hd de 6,5 pouces avec
un taux de rafraîchissement de 90 hertz
donc ça portera plus de fluidité lorsque
vous allez venir scrollé sur instagram
lorsque des applications nécessiteront
et notamment des jeux donc ça c'est
intéressant
un taux d'échantillonnage tactique de
180 m donc ils s'inscrivent plus dans ce
qu'on attend d'un smartphone aujourd'hui
en 2021
c'est pas le smartphone le plus lumineux
du marché on a un pic de luminosité 600
litres donc si vous allez en extérieur
en plein soleil et vous avez beaucoup de
soleil c'est pas là vous allez avoir le
plus grand confort en termes de lecture
c'est évident mais malgré tout regardez
ici on est en intérieures jai lumière au
dessus on va très bien ce qui se passe
regardons maintenant ce qu'il en est en
termes de photos parce que ça c'est un
usage c'est extrêmement important alors
je vous le montrer tout à l'heure on a
pas moins de trois capteurs photo on
croirait 4 mais nous on en a trois le
premier si c'est votre capteur principal
c'est un 48 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.8
et vous avez en dessous de petits
capteurs alors ici par contre
remy ne donne absolument aucune
information concernant le nombre de
mégapixels
on voit qu'on a une caméra macro et une
caméra portrait noir et blanc
configuration extrêmement basique mais
une fois de plus dans cette gamme de
prix
c'est très basique c'est comme ça et
rien de bien déconnant là dessus je n'ai
pas d'info est ce que c'est un 2
mégapixels est ce que c'est un 5
mégapixels
on n'en sait rien mais là évite peu
importe il ya l'avant une caméra de
cette fille de 16 mégapixels et ouvre à
f 2.0
on va se garder un petit peu
l'expérience logiciel ce qui va bien
nous intéresser ici c'est que on voit
qu'on peut faire plein de choses hein
vidéo portrait gnagnagna hockey photos
en plein jour caméra grand angle
je suis d'accord mode vidéo ici on va
pas venir faire de la vidéo accès
smartphones ne sais pas du tout un
smartphone qui a optimisé pour la vidéo
déjà vous n'avez absolument aucune
stabilisation optique on peut venir
faire des photos en mode nuit
avait également des petits effets qui
existent regarder qui nous ont mis juste
là si vous le souhaitez original or
moderne
en fait c'est des filtres cyberpunk
flamants roses
astral éblouissement à vous de voir si
ça vous intéresse moi personnellement je
pense que saddam globalement aujourd'hui
aucun intérêt mais ça existe donc si
vous voulez et bien vous pouvez venir le
faire la photo ok ça fonctionnera le
mode portrait si on souhaite je suis pas
non plus sûr qu'on faisait beaucoup de
photos en mode portrait mais si vous
voulez vous pouvez le faire pouchet en
48 mégapixels pour moi ça n'a aucun
intérêt
le 48e mégapixels vous servira pour deux
choses la première c'est capté plus de
luminosité avec cette technologie de cap
xl en hockey ça vous fera espèce de gros
pixels captera plus de lumière saha
jouera bien évidemment pour la photo de
lui mais a retenu je suis pas hyper
hyper fan et puis le deuxième intéressés
pour venir jouer puisque vous n'avez pas
effectivement deux téléobjectifs vous
venez vous mais vous êtes enfin vous
allez en x 2 x 5 et vous monter jusqu'à
x 10 voilà faut-il aller jusqu'à faut 10
je ne pense pas mais l'idée c'est
qu'effectivement eh bien voyez vous avez
votre 48 mégapixels vous venez zoomer en
x 2 vous êtes sur un 24 mégapixels
on se regarde le résultat dans quelques
instants voir si effectivement il ya 1
106 intéressant ou alors absolument pas
du tout et puis ensuite vous arrivez non
plus aidé en plus vous avez et si ce
qu'on appellera l'ultra macro on peut
venir faire des photos en macro juin 4
cm est ce réellement intéressant je ne
suis jamais à ip par la macro sauf quand
on la retrouve sur un capteur ultra
grand-angle on arrive à faire des choses
qui sont pas trop mal mais en règle
générale dans ce genre de configuration
ça me transcende pas en tout cas on voit
ici que on se retrouve avec un grand
standard dans cette gamme de prix donc
rien de bien surprenant ici 48 et puis
la macro et le mode portrait ok bon très
standard joue en quelques photos que
j'ai fait effectivement avec se réunit 8
5 g on est ici sur le capteur principal
globalement dans l'ensemble c'est pas
mauvais alors il ya beaucoup de lumière
on va pas avoir des couleurs qui vont
être extrêmement saturé s'est tout de
suite ce qui ressort de capteurs on le
voit on a un truc qui est assez neutre
et au niveau des hautes lumières on a eu
du mal ici on le voit un nouveau de
cette flore là il n'est pas extrêmement
bon niveau des hautes lumières il n'est
pas très saturé mais malgré tout il fait
le taf on continue ici on se rapproche
avec un zoom x 2 même reproche même
critique
rien de bien surprenant on vient
utiliser effectivement ce 48000 appel
pour venir
vous met dedans donc on obtient ce
résultat là et ça fonctionne et dès
qu'on se rapproche trop en faut dix
gardes et je vous montre quand même mais
là on oublie complètement et c'est
normal on continue pour voir
effectivement sur toutes ces questions
de contre-jour
il s'en sort pas trop mal on arrive bien
à voir tout ce qui se dessine en bas ici
au niveau des plantes on voit bien
toutes les feuilles rien est cramé on
voit le soleil ici on arrive à voir les
détails avec tous les nuages ça
fonctionne une fois de plus on n'a pas
des images qui sont particulièrement
saturé légèrement sous saturé on a une
légère compensation on le voit ici pour
me reconstituer les briques cette image
là bon c'est pas dingue dingue hausse a
fait le taf mais une fois de plus autour
de 150 euros
on se rapproche en x 2 même critique
même reproche ça fonctionne et dès qu'on
va beaucoup plus loin on récupère du
bruit on continue ici regardez là il
fait le taf mais on voit toujours une
fois de plus ce petit reproche que je
vais avoir à lui faire ici au niveau des
hautes lumières sur la fleur il a du mal
à côté de ça et ce qui est intéressant
c'est le détail qu'on va retrouver ici
au niveau des feuilles on voit bien les
différents ménages
on retrouve bien quand même pas mal de
détails donc dans l'ensemble c'est pas
trop mal si on oublie ce problème de
gestion de la lumière par moments si on
oublie effectivement le fait qu'il n'ait
pas trop saturé et bien dans l'ensemble
ça fait à x 2 x 10 et là on fait de la
macro alors la macro la macro c'est
intéressant moi je suis jamais trop fan
de macro sur les smartphones sur ces
capteurs dédié parce que ça marche pas
particulièrement bien même reproche que
je veux lui faire ici on peut faire des
petites choses on peut se marrer il faut
tendre trouver sa position mais c'est
pas extraordinaire les usages derrière
je suis pas sûr on peut le faire
voyez mais est ce pour autant vraiment
intéressant je ne suis pas complètement
sûr j'ai essayé de vous capturez une
petite toile d'araignée là c'est
difficile ça bouge a aucune
stabilisation optique sur les capteurs
macro bien écouter ce qu'on va venir
mettre qu'on a deux ou un 5 mégapixels
est ce qu'on va me permettre une
stabilisation optique ici non ça ne
servirait à rien et on la caméra de sel
film elle frôle teuf
franchement c'est un peu poussif par
endroits on le voit notamment au niveau
du bas du visage ici le mode portrait ac
la caméra portrait noir et blanc
eh bien ça fonctionne rien à dire
là-dessus correct et honnête et c'est ce
qu'on attend de feu de plusieurs
smartphones dans cette gamme de prix là
le char fait tilter avez une petite
photo de celle fissiles voyons perd un
peu en précision mais
voilà c'est pas c'est une fois de plus
ce traitement algorithmique qui est un
peu poussif là dessus mais rien de bien
surprenant
et puis j'ai essayé pas mal de choses au
niveau de la photo de nuit il a du mal
il a vraiment du mal à choper le point à
gérer ça je vous ai mis des petits
effets avec les filtres pour moi voyez
ça apporte pas grand chose c'est pas ouf
j'ai tenté effectivement également avec
moi il a du mal
il a vraiment du mal la gestion de la
lumière et pas d'un go enfin voilà une
fois de plus et mais ça me surprend pas
que dans cette gamme de prix on s'attend
pas à voir un smartphone qui sur des
photos de nuit fasse des merveilles et
le résultat est là et il ya des offres
qui sont intéressantes si ce smartphone
vous intéresse il ya des offres alors
j'ai tout noté
je les ai pas appris par coeur alors
regarde déjà sur le site de la fnac du
je vous ai mis tous les liens en bas en
descriptions il ya d'autre offre que je
n'ai pas les détails tout moment à
laquelle je tourne cette vidéo mais je
vous ai mis toutes les offres en bas
dans la description donc aller jeter un
petit coup d'oeil alors je vous le dis
comme ça vous saurez tout du 12 au 17
mai sur le site de la fnac sur la
version 6 giga de ram 128 giga de
stockage au tarif de 259 euros vous avez
votre reee 2008 et vous avez également
un stabilisateur un dj un os mobile 3
qui vous offert dans la limite dans la
limite des stocks disponibles
ça veut dire que vous pouvez prendre
votre smartphone et vous prenez votre
stabilisateur qui est juste là pour
aller filmer si vous souhaitez faire la
vidéo bah oui parce qu'effectivement
comme vous n'avez absolument aucune
stabilisation ici à la main le prendre
parti a filmé faire des vidéos c'est un
petit peu laventure tandis que si vous
prenez votre stabilisateur votre os
mobile 3 est bien là ça sera sousse
nickel vous allez pouvoir lire tout
commander la regarder l'âge ou le monde
d'en haut vous venez tout commander ici
vous avez un petit jaune pâle pour venir
le déplacer vous lancer l'enregistrement
voulait arrêter vous faites des fautes
aussi directement avec ça c'est pratique
ça marche bien donc ça c'est vraiment un
point super intéressant si effectivement
vous voulez le bien faire de la vidéo
avec votre smartphone donc ça c'est un
poc est super cool
et puis il ya une autre offre l'autre
offre l est du 18 au 20 mai vous avez un
remboursement immédiat toujours à la
fnac de 30 euros sur la version 628 et
s'avoue le ramène à 229 euros donc vous
avez un smartphone 5 g qui sera un des
tarifs les mieux positionnés du marché à
229 euros sont des offres limitées donc
si vous souhaitez les avoir il faut
vraiment gagner sur ces différentes
périodes là
une fois de plus je vous ai mis tous les
liens en bas dans la description le riz
mil 810g qui a des smartphones 5g le
moins cher du marché
voilà ce que j'avais à vous dire
aujourd'hui sur ce smartphone alors ce
smartphone là il est intéressant de remy
je sais pas si vous connaissez bien la
marque on en a déjà parlé
ils font également aussi et bien des
écouteurs ça ce sont les mêmes skew deux
qui sont aussi assez intéressant il ya
plein de produits chers ennemis la
marque se développe énormément il vient
démocratiser la 5g donc c'est une marque
que je trouve intéressante qui est très
agressif en termes de positionnement
tarifaire et qui vous permet d'avoir des
produits de bonne facture à des tarifs
extrêmement intéressant donc si vous
voulez un smartphone qui écoule un
smartphone qui est typé qui est un super
look qui fera à plein de choses sans en
faire trop bien évidemment une fois de
plus autour de 250 euros va pas lui
demander la lune est bien là vous avez
un smartphone qui intéressant le riz mil
8,5 g très bien positionnés en termes de
tarifs et qui je dirais vous permettra
d'avoir un usage mixte en termes de
visionnage de contenu en terme de photos
en termes de multimédia en termes de
gaming sans en demander trop et bien
évidemment avec la 5g aux alentours des
250 euros donc ça c'est intéressant
a vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez de ce smartphone est ce que vous
pourriez être intéressé par un
smartphone d'eurythmie est-ce que 2008 5
g celui-là il vous fait de l'oeil droit
du tout mark et moi bien évidemment tout
ça en bas en commentaire et quentin où
on se retrouve très vite pour continuer
à parler de teck et ça c'est une très
bonne nouvelle des bisous la mort ou
prenez soin de vous et à bientôt
ciao